thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story The Daily Mirror publisher
says sorry to Prince Harry as a court is
told the bosses must have known about
phone hacking carried out on an
industrial scale
after his sex abuse verdict Donald Trump
to face questions about his political
future though not from his loyal base
I'm going to deliver I'm gonna fight the
Witch and I'm gonna take care of
clearing my name and I look forward to
doing it
another Republican politician now
claiming a Witch Hunt this time a
congressman accused a fraud and money
laundering
in Pakistan more protests and an
internet shutdown as the former prime
minister Imran Khan is detained for
eight days
they are demanding change they want the
shape of this country to be completely
different
I don't care what they tell you in
school Cleopatra was black
and the ancient Egyptian Queen at the
center of a very modern row about race
plus we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's coming up
in our press preview from 10 30.
[Music]
hello there good evening it is the
latest Skirmish in the war between
Prince Harry and the tabloids over
privacy today on the first day of a
phone hacking trial at the high court
the publisher of the Daily Mirror
newspaper apologized unreservedly for
unlawfully gathering information about
the Duke of Sussex they say on one
occasion the court was also told the
systemic use of private investigators by
journalists to illegally obtain private
information was authorized by senior
editors including Piers Morgan well
those were the first revelations in a
case that will see a senior Royal give
evidence in court for the first time
Katie Spencer has this report
for all those keeping count this is
Prince Harry versus the papers round
three joining him to Coronation Street
stars and a comedian's ex-wife little in
common by the fact they all claim to
have been subjected to the most
intrusive methods of personal
information gathering
in their opening argument lawyers for
Harry claiming that from his mother's
death onwards as a Schoolboy in the Army
through to his life as a young adult he
was targeted by some mirror group
journalists who didn't think twice about
breaking the law to get their story
he claims they hacked his voicemail
causing no end of paranoia and distress
to those closest to him including former
girlfriend Chelsea Davey driving their
breakup
Harry's Barrister David sherb on KC
saying Prince or not the blatantly
unlawful methods used to get information
about Harry's life away from his Royal
duties was quite frankly appalling
as this trial gets underway Harry and
the other claimants will in turn be
called to give evidence it'll be the
first time since the 19th century that a
senior Royal has been called to the
witness box and before he's even spoken
a word a victory of sorts
in court documents released at the start
of the trial for the first time mgn
admitted to Having learned one of its
journalists paid a private investigator
75 pounds to an awfully find out what
the prince had been doing at London's
China White nightclub on one night back
in 2004 saying it apologized
unreservedly and accepting the prince
was entitled to compensation and that
wasn't all
while the publisher denies voicemail
interception and any involvement in the
case of Coronation Street actor Michael
Lavelle who was in court they said where
historical wrongdoing has taken place we
have made admissions take full
responsibility and apologize
unreservedly but we will vigorously
defend against allegations of wrongdoing
where our journalists acted lawfully mgn
insists it is now a very different
company but in this case the claimants
team alleged that over the course of 20
years at the mirror Sunday Mirror and
Sunday people unlawful information
gathering was happening on an industrial
scale authorized by senior editors
including Piers Morgan
Morgan has always denied any knowledge
of phone hacking but in court it was
claimed that on one occasion he was seen
standing in a group of reporters
laughing whilst playing out an illegally
obtained voicemail left by singer Paul
McCartney
Prince Harry's hatred of the British
tabloid press is well documented he
cited media intrusion as part of the
reason he and his wife moved to America
and in just a few weeks time in his own
words at this trial he'll tell his side
of that story Katie Spencer Sky News
former U.S president Donald Trump will
likely face questions from voters in a
few hours time about how he plans to run
another presidential campaign after he
was found to be a sex abuser he has said
he will appeal but still faces multiple
legal threats in several States those
ongoing cases could sway the undecided
voters who will likely decide his
political fate but not his loyal base as
Mark Stone has been finding out in Mount
Jackson Virginia
it is so often said that it's the people
of the rural counties and just a few of
America's states who can swing the
country's Direction
[Applause]
addo of Virginia's Blue Ridge Mountains
Donald Trump has always found his
loyalists
[Music]
as those who will never be moved
but beyond this loyalty is there a line
a point of no return for the former
president I don't think there's anybody
that's in politics that haven't done
something illegal or immoral Bobby
Rosenberger is a health worker and a
trump voter what do you make of of of
the news now that a jury in New York
has concluded that he's a sex offender I
think that everybody has made mistakes
in life
this happened years ago
up the road a conversation with Bobby
Jones it's a reminder to anyone who
might dismiss those who choose Trump
there is Nuance in their decisions that
I'm like I said he's a good man or bad
man all I'm saying is is that on my
stand of decency he at least did try to
help get rid of the abortion he did try
to help keep jobs going he did try to
keep jobs in the United States he tried
to look out for the people if he did
something immoral I don't agree with
that I think it's terrible but look at
what Biden's doing have mercy here in a
New York studio in another world the
woman who a jury concluded was sexually
assaulted by Donald Trump was deflecting
the mud already being thrown at her this
is not about the money this is about
getting my name back I'm overwhelmed
with happiness for the women of the
country it's really not about me so much
it's about every woman
her lawyer believes that in this video
evidence played in court Trump
incriminated himself with this
remarkable moment
that they can grab women but well that's
what it's if you look over the last
million years I guess that's been
largely too not always but largely true
unfortunately or fortunately
he continues to claim that he's never
met her
back in the place where it counts
another conversation which reveals so
much you know they just want to
crucified Trump so like I said they all
dirty but I like Trump better
[Laughter]
it's like America has got to a place
where the polarization the entrenchment
the distrust of the other is so deep
that nothing will shift views it's a
place where there is now an immunity to
the unacceptable
if the question is can a sex offender be
president we'll hear the answer feels
like yes Mark Stone Sky News in Virginia
now to another Republican politician
who's been embroiled in Scandal from the
moment he took office U.S congressman
George Santos was charged with fraud and
money laundering accused of defrauding
his donors and wrongly claiming
unemployment benefits this evening he
pledged to fight the witch Hunters our
U.S correspondent James Matthews reports
Paul his story is incredible literally
George Santos is the modern day Walter
Mitty at the heart of government
he's the congressman who's told lie
after lie the courts will test his
latest assertion that he's not guilty of
charges against him I appreciate
leadership for being patient at this
time and for allowing the process to
play out I think this is about innocent
until proven guilty this starts I have
my right to fight to prove my innocence
as the government has a right to fight
to try to find me guilty in whatever
on the campaign Trail Santos told a
Litany of lines including that he was an
ex-wall Street Banker who'd graduated
from prestigious colleges none of it was
true
Mr Santos do your lies make a mockery of
this place and of the American people
what would it take for you to resign Mr
Santos pardon me guys
is the Republican is the Republican
Party tainted by your fabrication sir
appreciate it good to see you should the
public believe anything you say thank
you
Santos has admitted to lying on his CV
but it hasn't stopped him keeping his
seat in the House of Representatives
Republican power Brokers know that his
removal would threaten their slim
majority I will
story has shifted to the court the
charges he faces include spending
political donations on himself claiming
unemployment benefit when he was in fact
employed and of lying to the House of
Representatives regarding his financial
affairs his political opponents have
delivered their holding verdict we're
digesting the uh the charging documents
but the level of fraud the level of
extremism uh the the continued you know
lies throughout all of this it's just an
unfortunate thing that
um that work all colleagues together and
this level of fraud that's been
perpetrated on the people of New York
the reality is
months I'm indicted
this latest twist and the Curious tale
of George Santos presents one hard truth
he might yet swap the seat of power for
a spell in prison James Matthews Sky
News in Washington
and we're gonna have
in Pakistan at least six people have
died and more than a thousand arrested
after violent protests over the
Detention of the country's former prime
minister Imran Khan the powerful
military has accused demonstrators of
trying to start a civil war during
what's been described as a black chapter
in the country's history well the
turmoil escalated when Imran Khan was
ousted in a no-confidence vote just over
a year ago in August last year he was
charged under anti-terror laws though
that case was later dropped a few months
later the election commission
disqualified him from running for public
office for five years and during a rally
in November the former prime minister
was shot in what he described as an
assassination attempt he was then
detained yesterday and will remain in
custody for at least eight days Sky's
Cordelia Lynch reports now from
Islamabad
we're ready to
[Music]
unacceptable
Imran Khan's supporters enraged and
unrelenting
this is what we're constantly seeing
pitched battles between protesters and
the police with no resolution in sight
they are demanding change they want the
shape of this country
to be completely different
[Applause]
[Music]
they feel Under Siege I'm a doctor I've
been in the protest since yesterday and
all security personnels all agencies
they are firing State fires on the
people the authorities they're not
taking care of the people you can see
what what's going on right now what we
want we just want to release Imran Khan
nothing else
after being dragged from a courtroom by
Pakistan's paramilitary Imran Khan was
back in another today a judge ruling he
could be held for eight days on
corruption charges which he denies his
team framing it as political persecution
foreign
[Music]
wherever you're standing this looks like
a very vulnerable moment
but the government insists the legal
process must play out
while the military vowed to take action
against anyone pushing Pakistan towards
Civil War
dictatorships and coups are part of
Pakistan's history and so are protests
the question is whether Imran Khan's
arrest will play into his hands or will
create the kind of violence that only
delays his Central goal for an early
election
what happens in the next few days could
help decide that right now though the
ground looks too unstable to judge
Cordelia Lynch Sky News Islamabad
Pakistan
it's been 20 years since scientists
first sequenced human DNA transforming
medical research but that so-called Book
of Life was based on the genes of one
man of mostly European descent today a
more inclusive version of the genetic
code was revealed which could help
personalize how diseases are treated as
our science correspondent Thomas Moore
explains
the human genome the blueprint of our
species a three billion letter long
genetic code with all the instructions
to make you or me or is it the official
sequence published in 2001 as the Human
Genome Project was largely based on a
man of white European descent known only
as rp11 who lived in Buffalo New York
it's a bias that matters because we're
now entering a new era of genetic
medicine and people of different
ancestries could miss out
99.9 of the human genome is identical
across the population it binds us
together as a species but the other 0.1
percent contains variations in the
genetic code that reflect our ancestry
now in a major undertaking scientists
have published the first pan genome it's
a genetic manual based not on just one
person but on 47 individuals of
different Heritage a first step to
reflecting diversity across the
population it includes 109 19 million
new variations in the genetic code and
more than 1100 repeated sections of DNA
that contain genes in effect they're
like slightly different translations of
a book that's been written in another
language as scientists say a better
understanding of more diverse DNA code
should stop some groups missing out on
genetic advances could be that somebody
is sick and we will be blind to the DNA
difference that is making them sick or
it could be because I believe that
genomics will become relevant even for
people and as part of their routine
Medical Care to keep them healthy that
we will be blind to a DNA difference
that they have that might put them at
risk for a certain condition take one
example the gene for lipoprotein a a
fatty molecule in the blood variations
in that Gene are responsible for the
biggest genetic risk for heart disease
in African Americans but only as a
result of the pan genome as that has
been understood and it could lead to
treatments that Target the Gene and are
more clinically effective two decades on
from the first sequence of the human
genome the book of life has been given a
long overdue rewrite so we can all
benefit from the revolution in genetic
medicine
Thomas More reporting there now the boss
of John Lewis pledged today that the
company will always remain employee
owned no ifs no buts after her
leadership was tested in a confidence
vote Dame Sharon White had been
considering selling a stake in the John
Lewis partnership which also owns
waitrose to an outside investor to try
to raise two billion pounds but after
falling profits and a canceled bonus
staff rebelled as our business
correspondent Paul Kelso reports
John Lewis is a Retail Group under a
cloud its private club on the banks of
the Thames the scenic setting for a
difficult meeting for chairwoman Dame
Sharon White
facing votes of confidence in her
leadership from staff known as partners
who also own the business she sought to
reassure them they would remain the boss
the John Lewis partnership will always
be an employee-owned business
a model is the very reason I joined the
partnership because I believe profoundly
in an approach of Kinder capitalism in
the 21st century that demonstrates our
ability to combine commercial Excellence
with social purpose
foreign
their support to take the company
forward but not to avoid defeat on her
performance last year when John Lewis
lost more than 230 million pounds and
she raised the prospect of seeking
outside investment for the first time
for the former boss of media regulator
ofcom who has no previous retail
experience it's a rebellion that
increases questions about her leadership
I personally believe that you have to
have an absolute focus on the trading
success with the gloriers of journalists
many people have been very kind about
the years where we were doing very well
and getting a good Financial return it
was an absolute Obsession on satisfying
our customers for decades of retail
Bellwether that clothed furnished and
reflected middle class Britain John
Lewis has been hit by competition online
and the High Street while its waitrose
customers have sought cheaper options
the reality is that when we get into a
cost of living prices what matters is
the best prices all the time and you
know what value do we put on value so I
think that's an interesting question
about how much we're prepared to pay but
unless John Lewis reminds us why they're
better why they're different and why
it's worth shopping with them we will
disappear
John Lewis's business model is unique it
gives its staff benefits like access to
this place and the power to hold
management to account now these votes
were non-binding purely symbolic but
they are a clear expression of concern
about whether the current leadership has
the know-how to preserve what makes it
different in a harsh business
environment
from Crockery to Christmas ads
hey Ellie hi John Lewis is an
institution but it wouldn't be the first
to discover there's no room for
sentiment on the High Street Paul Kelso
Sky News in cookham
the House of Lords has tonight been
debating the government's controversial
illegal migration bill under which
anyone who enters the UK illegally would
be deported and then receive a lifetime
ban on settlement citizenship and
re-entry among the critics of the bill
has been the Archbishop of Canterbury
it is isolationist it is morally
unacceptable and politically impractical
to let the poorest countries deal with
the crisis alone and cut our
International Aid
for speaking to Sky News this evening
the immigration Minister Robert generick
defended the government's approach
the Archbishop and others raised the
issue of morality well there's nothing
moral in perpetuating the trade of the
people Smugglers these were amongst the
most evil individuals in society today
and it's only by breaking their business
model decisively which is what this this
bill will do that we can achieve that
the Metropolitan Police has apologized
to the family of murdered private
investigator Daniel Morgan after
documents relating to his death were
found in a locked cabinet at New
Scotland Yard Mr Morgan was killed with
an ax in a car park back in 1987 an
independent review Into the unsolved
case accused the force of institutional
corruption in the way it concealed its
failings
Palestinian militants have fired
hundreds of rockets at Israel while
Israel is pressing ahead with air
strikes which have killed 21
Palestinians during the fighting
Egyptian State tv announced that Egypt
had broken a ceasefire between the
warring sides but shortly after that
announcement though Rockets continue to
be fired by both sides
the future of the play country leader
Adam price is in doubt this evening
after a damning report found the party
failed to implement a zero tolerance
approach to sexual harassment the
party's senior leadership is still
meeting this evening with Skye's
political correspondence Joe Pike is in
Cardiff and Joe a late night meeting
after a somewhat chaotic day
completely chaotic and at some political
parties act quickly decisively
ruthlessly to dispatch their leaders who
seem out of favor certainly implied
doesn't seem to be following that model
their meeting tonight the special
meeting of the national executive
started at two hours and 23 minutes ago
still no word as to the result of it and
it follows 24 hours of rampant
speculation that Adam price is out he's
finished he is gone why well because of
that very controversial damning report
about a culture within the party a toxic
culture of bullying of harassment and
also of misogyny even one former chief
executive of the party said that they
had been bullied why does all of this
matter well partly because apply to the
third party here at the seneth but also
because they have this corporate
cooperation agreement with the Welsh
government with Welsh labor because
labor 30 out of 60 seats they don't have
a majority and therefore Pride can help
them get through more controversial
legislation why is there this massive
delay or partly many think because there
is no clear successor to Adam Price
certainly if you discount uh one a
member of the Senate who said that they
will move to Parliament or want to move
to to Westminster therefore we're in
this sort of weird waiting game the
meeting is still ongoing we don't know
if Adam price is staying or going and as
you say Anna it's all pretty chaotic and
pretty fast
Joe we'll see what happens thank you
now there's a lot that we already know
about Cleopatra she was Egypt's last
pharaoh famed as a great Beauty and
according to historians she ended her
life by allowing herself to be bitten by
a deadly Cobra but her appearance and
the color of her skin has been opened to
interpretation that uncertainty and the
casting of a mixed-race British actress
and a new Netflix series has ignited a
row of a race and representation has the
story
it's a docudrama series about an
Egyptian queen but the real drama is
playing out off-screen I would die for
Egypt
what would you die for casting Adele
James a mixed race British actor as
Cleopatra has triggered a petition and a
lawsuit out of outrage and now a
government-owned Egyptian broadcaster is
making its own documentary perhaps in
protest I don't think it's about
Blackness or afrocentrism I think it's
about how Netflix or how Western media
is imposing a certain Narrative of our
own history and excluding Egyptians from
this kind of history that they weren't
told accurately Cleopatra was an
Egyptian queen of Macedonian descent
possibly with a Persian and black
African background too though this is
deeply contested so much so the Egyptian
government is insisting the ruler had
lighter skin
this Elizabeth Taylor adaptation they
say was fictional not a documentary
[Music]
Dr salian Ashton worked on the series
she says skin tone is irrelevant we're
trying to impose modern racialized terms
such as black or white
um on an ancient culture that didn't
recognize those terms so I don't think
it is helpful
um I think you know I'd far rather be
talking about sort of Cleopatra's
achievements as a strong female
character and role model potentially a
depiction that is open to interpretation
but as they're finding out for some
retelling history comes with a risk of
rewriting it ashenahara nagascar news